Colin Kaepernick accuses white adoptive
parents of problematic upbringing
perpetuating racism
this this is not a a joke by the way
this is actually what he said okay
so
uh Colin Kaepernick formal NFL star and
activist used his white adoptive parents
of perpetuating racism in a new
interview in his upcoming graphic novel
change the game Kaepernick spoke about
growing up in a problematic household
and how his parents tried to steer him
in a Direction they thought was best
which led to several fights between them
and their adopted son one of those
discriments Illustrated in the novel was
a fight over his hairstyle Kaepernick
wanted to wear cornrows but his mother
pushed back a legend saying oh your hair
is not professional oh you look like a
little Thug the lack of racial Harmony
in his home uh own home encouraged
Kaepernick to find Community elsewhere
and he chose to pursue a football career
instead of a professional baseball
career because they were significantly
more blacks in the NFL and MLB
Kaepernick still hopes to return to the
NFL and has worked as an activist and
advocate for social justice issues I I
have like so many different issues
issues with this article here but I'll
go to you first man go ahead I just
so if you're Colin Kaepernick you're
adopted
by
what is where's parents white what were
they yeah if you can pull up okay the
the Colin Kaepernick's sales
if someone adopts you
I assume they take you out of a foster
care
or of a situation that you probably
don't want to be in so this family
adopts Colin Kaepernick
and now he resents the fact that they
adopted him because they're saying hey
if you do certain things people are
going to judge you you know what's crazy
I actually had a conversation yesterday
randomly with uh our friend Jerry who
works upstairs in the sales department
black guy right and he's sitting there
with April another black woman great
great Duo if they're watching shout out
to them and he literally just put
cornrows in his hair did you see it I go
oh hey nice new hairdo he goes yeah man
I've been wanting to do this like for
years
but my family were I believe their
Seventh-Day Advent uh Venice at Venice
and he goes this is very much frowned
upon I said oh okay tell me why he goes
yeah you know cornrows tattoos this is
something you just can't do and he's a
black guy I go all right explain he's
like it just it's just frowned up on
he's he's explaining to me why all right
cool got it so this isn't a race thing
this is a culture thing right and so for
instance it'd be the equivalent of a
white guy just growing as long hair out
and listening to heavy metal and his
parents saying hey if you actually want
to be taken seriously you probably can't
just
you know look like Axl Rose out there or
slash just with hair flowing if you want
to actually be taken seriously like that
so wouldn't you agree that your parents
probably your adoptive parents want the
best for you
it would just seem that Colin Kaepernick
has sort of Lost
Common Sense Tom
I I would feel different than I do right
now if over the course of the last 10
years
you've been hearing him say I only
played football because I thought there
was more racial diversity in the sport
I didn't hear that I didn't hear that
and no we heard a lot about Colin uh Kim
and I Solomon airport by himself not
very famous
um
and he was very chill and I don't
remember comments made like that and he
maybe he can say he's repressed and all
that but to suddenly come out and I also
didn't remember him saying you know you
know I've lived in a repressed household
I just feel like you know each step he
has to appropriate some other offense to
continue to
you know press his relevance and he is
relevant he brought attention to some
things
um some in the right way some in the
wrong way and some were positive some
not I'm just kind of shocked now that
now it's time to you know go attack a
bunch of other things and I haven't
heard that his parents were these tough
people they adopted him you know
adoption is an act of Charity you know
they owe him respect as he grows up just
as he owes them respect it's called
family let me tell you man I have so
many problems with this uh first of all
his biological mother Heidi I believe
Russo gave him up at five weeks okay
until today the biological father they
don't know who it is it's unknown okay
so if it's unknown I mean I don't want
to get graphic but you understand what
that means yeah the only way somebody's
unknown it's because
you know you had a lot of different
partners she was very friendly let's
just say yeah so okay so so let's let's
put the perspective then there's the
adopted parent the parents that adopted
you so there's four people in this
in this situation here for you to
recognize and not recognize till 2021 he
didn't want to meet his mother his
biological mother
for giving up for adoption you have your
father who you don't know who he is you
have your biological mother
who you don't want to meet then you have
the parents that adopted you and you
think you made it into the NFL
let me get this straight you think you
made it to the NFL all on your own
seriously
do you think you did that
and I'm sorry you know the the role that
parents play to buy the uniforms to take
you to practice to be part of leagues
and drive you an hour or fly you out and
bring coaches and do you know how many
thousands of hours his parents or mother
sacrifice
and this is what you say just to sell a
story in a documentary it's a slap in a
face to parents do you know what this
does to people that are considering to
adopt this is the fear of parents that
are afraid to adapt you mean you want
parents to put 15 20 years of their
lives into adopting a kid in 20 years
later they get some like this because
now you have money you don't need them
anymore
it's the ultimate insult it's
um disgusting if you ask me there's no
parent that is perfect but anybody that
chooses to adopt you give you a home
take care of you and now you have this
kind of a life because of what they did
to sacrifice thousands of hours there's
nobody in the world there's there's two
people in the list of your life
that you should never be able to
criticize and it's the two
parents that adopted you those two
people you need to lift up and turn them
into Heroes forever you cannot say
anything about those two specifically in
an embarrassing way like this
adoption is a choice anyways and those
parents did not care what color you were
yeah and they adopted you so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign